I also comprises and welcome to we're
gonna do a Q&A hey about that just just
to be original for once
so I asleep rose to give me some
questions on Twitter and I asked you
bros to be as serious as possible
because all I get these days it's just
random [ __ ] to piss me off
so the first serious question is from
Wi-Fi howl how much do you ship Dan Phil
Jesus Christ this is gonna be the new
fist me daddy like Dan and Phil dad and
Phil Gannett field Dan and Phil I ask a
question Gannon fail everyone wants to
see them [ __ ] but it's not gonna happen
just let it go
Dean surgeon says what's the meaning of
life 42 baby who is God's sense what is
Edgar SAS tastes like I don't know I
mean why would I know that you tasted it
last night [ __ ] you don't know that you
look stone this bocce Smasher bro Muncie
your fav Disney movie
Cinderella have you ever laughed so hard
you poop your pants
no have you what is the last photo you
saved on your phone me as a unicorn
banana foreheads do you fold or scrunch
toilet paper I don't I don't use toilet
paper
oops key to lick your toes that's not
this is not a question it's not that
[ __ ] hard as proof okay you know I
find you happy now you happy and as we
look upon the face of insanity we can no
only darkness did you have many friends
as a child no I I think it's better to
have less friends maybe one or two would
you rather have of it would you rather
have a vagina on your forehead or a row
of pieces down your back what would I
rather be called vagina face or penis
back boots penis back pills thank you
very much obvious question hot sure howl
Jennifer Lawrence yes or yes no Jennifer
Lawrence just tries so hard to be liked
that it's just painful damn that's sick
burn yeah I know babe a Baskin do you
believe in Flying Spaghetti Monster
yes yes I do Alex Manoli is Edgar
secretly a porn star I wasn't supposed
to say anyone this but don't don't no no
excuse me sorry gotta change question
now do you ship phan next one dead
travesty
can you speak when your mouth is shut
this question better be in your video
parenthesis
isn't even a question LMAO LMAO doom
m.49 how do you look with a viking beard
let's have a look shall we
I don't like it
if Medusa's hair is made out of snakes
does that mean her pubes are made out of
snakes - what's wrong with you of course
of course they are bloomin and eat
Pokemon or Digimon hey why does one have
to exclude the other they're both
awesome pokemon is probably better Shaun
Sweeney one two three
what was your very first computer I had
a shitty HP laptop that if I put it on
my lap I would literally get burned
damages from the heat because it was
just so over overheated Cheyenne Mary
are you wearing sucks right now no
soccer socks are for [ __ ] Ezio 4:35
how did you start to be a youtuber well
like any other youtuber Ezio we were
just born out of our goddamn mind lon
and we didn't Megan why were a lot of
youtubers engineers then became
youtubers because no one actually wants
to become an inch it's much more fun to
just play games Elaine how about that
who would have thought I craft Taylor
fits me until there is nothing left but
my bones okay well that was a great Q&A
session as always heber's really really
make good great questions I really do
think I'm very proud um oh you're
[ __ ] you're so [ __ ] weird Bruce
thank you for watching this video and I
will see you in the next one double
brofist